You may have seen this demonstration before.
If you spray a solution of sodium salts with
ethanol through a flame
you get a characteristic orangey-yellow colour.
This is because when we heat up sodium
it emits a very specific wavelength of light
that our eyes see as orangey-yellow.
But look what happens when we do the same
experiment
in the light of a sodium streetlamp.
It looks really amazing even to the naked
eye.
The edge of the flame really looks like it
is actually black.
That's mad! What are you doing?
This is witchcraft, this isn't science!
I feel like I'm watching a special effect.
So how does this work?
Let's have a look at the flame in ordinary
light.
Here we have a solution of ethanol with some
sodium salts.
As you can see it's glowing the characteristic
orangey-yellow colour.
The usual explanation for this is when you
heat up the sodium
the electrons in the orbitals around the nucleus
get excited
and they jump up to higher energy levels.
As they drop back down, they release their
energy as a photon of light.
Quantum theory tells us that electrons and
atoms can only exist
at very specific discrete energy levels.
So this photon can only have certain energies.
As a photon's energy determines its wavelength
if that wavelength is in the visible spectrum,
our eyes will pick it up as a specific colour.
Sodium atoms have two very strong electron
transitions at 589 and 589.6 nm.
Which our eyes see as a deep yellowy colour.
To all intents and purposes these two wavelengths
are so close together
that they're indistinguishable.
So you can think of this yellow light as monochromatic
and made up of just one colour.
So how do we see the black flame effect?
First we need our yellow light.
This is a sodium street light or a low pressure
sodium lamp.
I actually bought this one off ebay, it originally
came from an army depot.
If you send electric discharge through this
inner tube which is filled with gas,
it glows to create the monochromatic yellow
light that we've been talking about.
When streetlights first come on in the evening
you might notice that they're this pink colour.
That's because there's neon and a little bit
of argon gas inside the tube
which when we send electricity along it, it
gets excited and glows pinkish red.
That's actually only there to heat up and
vaporise the sodium
that you can see in little dots along the
tube.
When the sodium vaporises, those atoms get
excited
and give out the lovely monochromatic yellow
colour you can see here.
We don't just get this yellow light out of
sodium lamps.
These pickles are soaked in brine or salt
water so they are jam-packed with sodium.
When we put a huge voltage across them they
heat up, the sodium gets excited
and they give off that lovely yellow light.
But I digress, let's get back to the black
flames.
The reason for this effect is because in the
same way
that sodium atoms tend to emit light of a
certain wavelength, around 589 nm,
they also tend to absorb light of that specific
wavelength.
And this makes the flame look dark.
It's strange to think of a flame as dark
because as we know flames give out light.
But the sodium is absorbing the light from
the lamp.
That light isn't reaching the camera and so
the flame looks dark.
Thanks for watching.
If you like this video, don't forget to subscribe,
and the Ri is now on Patreon so if you want
to support us, click the link above.